SENATE. THE SENATE THURSDAY
JANUARY TWENTY EIGHTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE CONTENTION OF THE
JOINT RULES COMMITTEE WILL COME
TO ORDER. COLLEAGUES GOOD
MORNING. RANDY JUST TO LET YOU
KNOW THE- SENATE CONTENTION OF
THE JOINT RULES COMMITTEE WILL
MEET FIRST AND THEN WE WILL
ADJOURN THIS AND GO TO OUR
REGULAR RULES COMMITTEE THAT'S
WHY YOU SEE YOUR COLLEAGUES UP
HERE THEY'RE THE ONES THAT WILL
STAY WE DON'T HAVE TO DO EXTRA
CLEANING AND YOU'RE JUST TO.
EVERYONE IS IMPORTANT JUST THE
EXPLAINING THE PROCESS. SO IN
RESPONSE TO COBIT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES- WE MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
AT HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING.
AND FACE COVERING GUIDELINESIN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE. THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO OUR LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH ONE OF OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SENATOR BATES.
PARTICIPATING IN THE HEARING
REMOTELY WITH THE USE OF THE
VIDEO CONFERENCE SYSTEM. I SEE
HER SENATOR BATES WHEN YOU GO
AHEAD THE DATA YOURSELF NOW AND
ANYONE THAT IS IN WITH WITH YOU
IN THE ROOM IN WHICH YOU ARE.
YES SIGNATURE ON BATES HERE AND
WITH ME IT WAS LAST OUT FOR A
RUN YOUR REAR END. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR TO ALLOW
PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HAD TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING-
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. BEFORE WE
BEGIN TODAY'S AGENDA WE NEED TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM I. AND TO
THE COLLEAGUES ARE PROJECTS NOT
EVERYONE HAS A MICROPHONE THE
MEMBERS UP HERE NO TO TURN
THEIR MIKE ON BUT I WANT TO
MAKE SURE. BOB MADAM SECRETARY
WILL YOU CALL THE ROLL. FAITH.
I DIDN'T HEAR YES I'M HERE
BATES HERE DRAWS ALL. RATHER
HERE HERTZBERG YOUR PREFERRED
HERE LEHRER HERE THEY'RE HERE
LEYVA HERE LATELY HERE MCGUIRE.
THE CARD HERE NIELSEN. HERE AND
HERE ROTH- ROTH HERE RUBIO.
SKINNER YOUR INTERFERE I'M
BURKE. WILK PRESIDENT WILL
PRESENT ATKINS HERE ATKINS HERE.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES I'M THE
SECRETARY NOTES- QUORUM HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED AND BEFORE WE
BEGIN THE AGENDA I WANT TO
QUICKLY TALK ABOUT THE PURPOSE
OF THIS MEETING AT THE
BEGINNING OF EACH LEGISLATIVE
SESSION THE JOINT RULES
COMMITTEE MUST ESTABLISH THE
CHAIR AND THE CHIEF
ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER FOR THE
COMMITTEE PURSUANT TO JOINT
RULE FORTY ADDITIONALLY THE
COMMITTEE MUST APPROVE PRESS
CREDENTIALS FOR THE REGULAR
LEGISLATIVE SESSION THE PRESS
CONCURRENT CREDENTIALS EXCUSE
ME MEMBERS WILL BE TAKEN UP AT
ANOTHER TIME. THE MEMBERS OF
THE JOINT RULES COMMITTEE OF
EACH HOUSE MAY MEET SEPARATELY
AND CONSIDER ANY ACTION THAT IS
REQUIRED TO BE TAKEN BY THE
JOINT RULES COMMITTEE IF THE
MAJORITY OF MEMBERS AT THE
SEPARATE MEETING VOTE IN FAVOR
OF INACTION THAT ACTION SHALL
BE CONSIDERED APPROVED BY THE
JOINT RULES COMMITTEE SO WITH
THAT UNDERSTANDING OF WHY WE'RE
MEETING TODAY IN LINE WITH THE
RULES AS WE- TAKE UP THE AGENDA
BEFORE US WE HAVE TWO ITEMS.
ITEM NUMBER ONE IS THE ELECTION
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEN COOLEY
AS CHAIR OF THE JOINT COMMITTEE
ON RULES AND ITEM NUMBER TWO IS
THE ELECTION OF DEBRA GRAVERT
AS THE CHIEF ADMINISTRATIVE
OFFICER OF THE JOINT COMMITTEE
ON RULES OUT WITH THE
PERMISSION OF THE BODY I WOULD
LIKE TO TAKE BOTH OF THESE
ITEMS AT THE SAME TIME UNLESS I
HAVE CONCERNS ITEM ONE AND ITEM
TO SOMEONE. THANK YOU MR
MAJORITY LEADER WE HAVE A
MOTION. FIVE MEN SECRETARY WILL
YOU CALL THE ROLL. HE I DRAWS
ALL. RAZZLE I HEARD FOR FIVE
AYE LAYERED. AYE LEYVA HI AYE
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE NIELSEN PAN
ALL RIGHT YEAH HI RALPH RIGHT
ROTH AYE RUBIO. SKINNER I HAVE
A MEMBER WELL. I LOOK AYE
ATKINS AYE ATKINS AYE. ELEVEN
THAT MEANT THAT MEASURE PASSES
WITH ELEVEN VOTES AND I AM
GONNA GO AHEAD AND CLOSE THE
ROLE BECAUSE WE HAVE MORE THAN
A QUORUM OF PRESENCE SO MADAM
SECRETARY IF YOU WILL. ARE
ACTUALLY AS- I. SHE'S GONNA GET
A LITTLE. I THE DIFFERENCE OUR-
MEMBER WHO J. JOINED US- I
SENATOR WE ARE VOTING AS YOU
PROBABLY HAVE DONE MANY TIMES
IN THE PAST ON ITEM ONE AND
ITEM TWO. COLLEAGUES I'M GONNA
GO AHEAD AND REPEAT MYSELF JUST
QUICKLY FOR THE FOR THE BENEFIT
OF OUR COLLEAGUES HAVE JOINED
US AND LET ME JUST SAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH THIS IS A BIG.
JOINT COMMITTEE BOB IT
CERTAINLY IS. WHEN WE ARE NOT
IN A PANDEMIC AND WE MEET WITH
THE ASSEMBLY AND IT IS TRULY
THE JOINT. OF RULES CONTINUE
COMMITTEE. AS I STATED I A
LITTLE BIT EARLIER FOR THE BODY
PRESENT. AT THE AT THE
BEGINNING OF EACH LEGISLATIVE
SESSION THE JOINT RULES
COMMITTEE HAS TO ESTABLISH A
CHAIR AND CHIEF ADMINISTRATIVE
OFFICER THE COMMITTEE PURSUANT
TO JOINT ROLE FORTY. THAT IS
WHAT WE ARE DOING TODAY. AND SO
ARE ALSO- IN LIGHT OF THE
PANDEMIC THE MEMBERS OF THE
JOINT RULES COMMITTEE OF EACH
HOUSE MAY MEET SEPARATELY. AND
CONSIDER ANY ACTION THAT'S
REQUIRED TO BE TAKEN BY THE
JOINT RULES COMMITTEE. IF THE
MAJORITY OF MEMBERS AT THE
SEPARATE MEETING VOTE IN FAVOR
OF AN ACTION THAT ACTION SHALL
BE CONSIDERED APPROVED BY THE
JOINT RULES COMMITTEE. I GIVE
THAT EXPLANATION FOR OUR TWO
COLLEAGUES WHO JUST JOINED US
SO WE ARE VOTING ON TWO ITEMS.
ITEM ONE THE ELECTION OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEN COOLEY. AS
THE CHAIR OF THE JOINT. OUR
COMMITTEE ON RULES AND ITEM
NUMBER TO THE ELECTION OF DEBRA
GRAVERT. AS CHIEF
ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER OF THE
JOINT COMMITTEE ON RULES WE
HAVE A MOTION MADE BY OUR
MAJORITY LEADER. WE HAVE
ALREADY HAD ONE VOTE. MADAM
SECRETARY CAN I ASK YOU TO CALL
THE ABS ARE THE REMAINING
MEMBERS. NIELSEN ALL RIGHT THE
OFFENSE I. ON BURKE. NUMBER I.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH COLLEAGUES
THAT PASSES THIRTEEN MADAM
SECRETARY- WITH ONLY ONE
ABSENCE SO THAT MEASURE PASSES
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES. WE WILL
CLIP WE CLOSE THE ROLE AND SO
NOW WE WILL ADJOURN. THE
MEETING OF THE SENATE
CONTENTION OF THE JOINT
COMMITTEE ON RULES WITH MY
GREAT THANKS TO MY COLLEAGUES
FOR BEING HERE FOR THIS. THANK
YOU WE WILL NOW TAKE OF. FIVE
MINUTES- AND WE WILL GET SET UP
FOR THE RULES COMMITTEE MEETING
THAT WE HAVE SCHEDULED FOR
TODAY. SEPARATE THE JOINT
CONTINGENT COMMITTEE ON RULES.